pictionary I'm the managing director of
the National skill development
corporation in India I was part of the
session on closing the gender gap in
South Asia the session talked about why
there was a gender gap and what could be
done to Bridget what was interesting is
that the first thing that came about was
the ginger gender gap was basically what
is between a years and how we actually
view the gender and gender gap rather
than any other aspect the second issue
that really emerged was that talking
about access to education mindset of
people employing people and women and
and others in the economy and looking at
the whole opportunity for participation
of different women and in fact the
people in the economic system one of the
thoughts was that because of the lack of
economic activity there was no pressure
on people to join the economic workforce
or look at participating actively so
some of the solutions that really
emerged were the need to look at an end
to end solution the need to be flexible
to allow people to take up professions
and take up education at times that they
wanted to and not put them in rigid
systems we needed to focus on on
improving the corporate sector response
to employing people and sharing best
practices there was a huge focus on folk
on the education part of it it was I
think the best part of the session was
that it concluded in a very positive
note that it is possible because of the
youth that are coming out in countries
like India which will tradition which
will challenge traditional mindsets look
at a new way of doing things that can
enable us to bridge this gender gap in
the next few years